[Musik]
Freiheit nur für meine Meinung müssen
wir wieder streiten lernen und damit
einen herzlichen guten Abend liebe
Zuschauer Donnerstagabend sie sind wir
sind es auch worüber darf man lachen was
ist eigentlich booknis und tut das weh
und streiten wir nur über Worte oder um
mehr das fragen wir uns und diese Gäste
der Philosoph Julian nieder Rümelin
die Autorin Düsen TK
die influencerin Leonie Löwenherz Plan
und Hape Kerkeling
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner und
die begrüßt alle Gäste ausgesprochen
herzlich heute abend Witzigkeit kennt
keine Grenzen hat ja 1993 mit Heinz
Schenk zusammen gesungen vielleicht ja
doch Fragezeichen ja Gottschalk hat
heute abend Jan schlimmste ist der hat
Stall Freunde der lief hinten wund auf
dem Steiß krümmt sich jetzt haben wir
hinten so eine feldfrische aufgebaut da
ist auch schon eine Thailänderin an ihm
am rumkneten hat noch eben stöhnend
hinter der Bühne hat er mir verraten bei
Wetten das Sitzen die schärfsten Hasen
es soll mal oh ja hier sitzen Schafe
Hasen mein lieber Herr Gesangsverein ihr
lassen wir aber krachen hier sitzt schon
scharfer Hase hör mal du bist ein Schafe
Hase alles was hier um Dich herumsitzt
das sind so Familienprogramm hier siehst
aber du bist ein scharfer Hase
schätzelein du bist nach meinem Arsch
weißt du was ich bin Organspender
brauchst du schwach
gibt es Witze die sie heute nicht mehr
machen würden also das was ich da
gemacht habe fällt ja unter Travestie
und der organspenderwitz ist natürlich
unter uns widerlich den würde ich privat
auch nicht bringen sondern in der Rolle
ob das aber heute noch so funktionieren
würde als Horst Schlämmer wage ich zu
bezweifeln ich glaube den Leuten würde
das Lachen im Heise stecken bleiben weil
könnte man so nicht mehr bringen
Horst Schlämmer der Prototyp weißer
alter Mann oder
Horst Schlämmer ist garantiert der
Prototyp weißer alter Mann da ich aber
glaube ich nicht der Prototyp weißer
alter Mann bin hatte ich das Gefühl ich
darf mich über die weißen alten Männer
und muss mich über die weißen alten
Männer lustig machen heute würde man das
nicht mehr machen aus Angst vor einem
Shitstorm oder weil man es nicht mehr
lustig findet
also wenn ich das so sehe ich habe davon
eigentlich nichts zurückzunehmen und vor
einem Shitstorm hätte ich ehrlich gesagt
auch keine Angst ich bin weder bei
Facebook noch bei Twitter insofern würde
ich gar nichts von dem Shitstorm merken
und schon sind wir bei einem wunderbaren
gegenüber nämlich bei Leonie klar
Historikerin influencerin die coole
Gemeinde kennt sie als Frau Löwenherz im
Netz
wenn eigentlich hinter jedem Witz eine
Diskriminierung steckt weil Humor
funktioniert immer auf Kosten von
jemandem ja also eine Diskriminierung
von Frauen oder von Schwulen oder von
Ausländern worüber lachen wir dann noch
ich glaube tatsächlich nicht das Witze
nur durch Diskriminierung funktionieren
weil wenn ein Witz nur dann funktioniert
oder wenn nicht nur dann witzig sein
kann wenn ich Minderheiten diskriminiere
dann bin ich vielleicht nicht so witzig
wie ich glaube
es können auch Mehrheiten sein die Frage
Mannes oder das Karnevals oder was auch
immer möchte ich nach oben oder nach
unten drehen und in dem Moment wo ich
über Minderheiten Witze mache den ich
gesellschaftlich durch meine Privilegien
überstellt bin den auf die ich macht
ausübe in dem Moment trete ich natürlich
nach unten deswegen fand ich Horst
Schlämmer tatsächlich auch als Charakter
ziemlich interessant weil er ja diesen
alten weißen Mann verkörpert also gerade
da sich über die eigene Gruppe lustig zu
machen und für die Zeit in der Horst
Schlämmer das große Ding war sie meinen
das letzte Jahrhundert
aber für die Zeit war natürlich eine
Überzeichnung dessen was das ausgemacht
hat ich glaube allerdings auch dass bei
dieser Art von Humor dass das über die
Köpfe von vielen hinweg geht die lachen
dann tatsächlich über den rassistischen
Witz und nicht über die Meter Ebene das
kann sein diskutieren wir gleich und
freuen uns über Julia niederrömelin
Philosoph
stellvertretender Chef des Ethikrates in
Deutschland Herr niederrömelin Humor
darf eigentlich alles über Humor kann
man nicht streiten satire darf alles
sind diese Zeiten vorbei fürchten sie
die Empfindlichkeiten am zugenommen ist
ganz klar und manchmal hat man auch den
Eindruck dass die ironische Sprache
gefährlicher geworden ist weil die Leute
die Ironie nicht verstehen ja so und
dann ist natürlich sagen wir wenn man da
Auffassung ist dass die Gesellschaft
zerfällt im Gemeinschaften die
untereinander ein Modus wenn die haben
der sehr fragil ist und der darf nicht
in irgendeiner Weise tangiert werden
dann wird es glaube ich schwieriger für
Humor aber ich bin da kein Experte also
wenn wir heute noch testen Düsen ist bei
uns und darüber freuen wir uns auch
Journalistin Autoren diesen
Karnevalskostüme schon angesprochen als
Scheich als Eskimo als Indianer ein
Frauenchor mit Sombrero warum sind das
keine
ja angenehmen Festivität Raketen mehr
keine irgendwie harmlosen Vergnügen mehr
ich glaube gar nicht so sehr dass wir
empfindlicher geworden sind sondern dass
der Diskurs sich erweitert hat und dass
die Menschen die betroffen sind
inzwischen sehr gut für sich selber
sprechen können und das ist da auch um
selbst Ermächtigung geht also ich glaube
das Humor der von Menschen umgesetzt
wird die selber aus den Communitys
kommen die schenken sich ja auch nichts
die
nehmen sich ja auch auseinander im
besten Sinne dass der absolut erlaubt
sein sollte und dass der auch möglich
ist aber ich glaube schon dass wir in
Zeiten leben wo wir das ein bisschen
sensibler betrachten können ohne dass
uns das Lachen vergeht also wenn meine
Arbeit kennt der weiß dass wir
vermeintlich wenig zu lachen haben und
trotzdem glaube ich dass Humor ein ganz
wichtiges Ventil ist das geht ja nicht
darum jemanden zu verlachen sondern
gemeinsam miteinander sich zu amüsieren
und was dabei witzig ist und was nicht
das muss auch unter Einbeziehung der
Menschen passieren und natürlich können
wir uns erinnern dass früher diese
Kostüme weniger problematisch waren als
heute beispielsweise aber ich glaube
dass das sehr viel damit zu tun hat wie
man das vermittelt also ich glaube das
ist schwierig ist Dinge zu verbieten und
zu sagen das darfst du nicht sondern es
geht eher darum was vorzuleben und ich
finde das zum Beispiel ganz treffend
beim z-wort also wo ich auch viele
Aktivisten kenne die sind jetzt hier und
Ronja sind und die eben sagen dass
dieses Wort sie verletzt weil ihre
Großeltern bevor sie vergast worden sind
im Zweiten Weltkrieg das Zet eingeritzt
bekommen haben auf dem Oberarm und wenn
das jemand weiß dann kann er sich ja
dreimal überlegen ob er dieses Wort
benutzen will oder nicht als wenn man
dann so argumentiert dass man sagt das
darfst du nicht das ist verboten ich
glaube das funktioniert nicht sondern es
geht wirklich um Sensibilität und das
haben wir auf allen Ebenen das merken
wir auch beim Android beispielsweise
aber auch bei dem Wort oder
ich darf das benutzen weil ich
selber die diskriminierungserfahrung
durchlaufen habe aber vielleicht fragen
wir das noch mal und bleiben noch mal
eine Sekunde Humor also wenn Migranten
nur noch über Migranten Witze machen
können und Frauen nur noch über Frauen
und Schwule nur noch über Schwule und
dicke nur noch über dicke ist das dann
eine
diskriminierungsfreie humorzone vor
Platz absolut nicht ich würde auch gar
nicht sagen dass dieser Humor innerhalb
dieser Gruppen bleibt oder bleiben muss
sondern wir eben schon gesagt habe es
geht darum trete ich nach oben oder nach
unten also es ist was anderes wenn ich
als
lesbische Frau einen Witz über hetero
Männer machen da trete ich nach oben das
sind die Menschen von denen ich
Diskriminierung erfahre wenn diese
Männer aber letzten feindliche Witze
über mich machen dann hat das eine ganz
andere macht Ebene und diese Macht
Ebenen sind eben sehr komplex innerhalb
auch von Community ist wenn wir sind
beide Teil der lgbtq+
gleichzeitig ist aber Herr Kerkeling ein
Mann und ich eine Frau also ich habe
durch meinen meinen Geschlecht noch mal
weniger Privilegien gleichzeitig sind
wir beide weiß gleichzeitig haben wir
beide keine sichtbare Behinderung sind
also auch innerhalb unserer Community
extrem privilegiert okay das heißt das
wie sie kein Problem damit hätten wenn
und das passiert ja auch habe
beispielsweise ich schwule von einem
heterosexuellen gespielt werden sollen
es Diskussionen darüber gibt sogar
infektionalen Produktionen nicht nur
unter Hollywood sondern auch hier in
Deutschland
sogenannte
Helfer an die Seite gestellt werden die
vermeiden sollen dass Menschen besonders
verletzt oder diskriminiert werden
selbst wenn man fiktionale Produkte
herstellt also Serienteile herstellt
oder so ihnen ist so etwas auch passiert
glauben Sie das ist eine Hilfe dass wir
da achtsamer werden aufmerksamer werden
also dass wir aufmerksamer werden auch
auf unsere Sprache achten und schauen wo
findet Diskriminierung statt die wir
vorher nicht wahrgenommen haben das ist
sicherlich ganz wertvoll aber bei der
Frage die sie mir Stellen fragt ich mich
was habe ich in den letzten 30 40 sagen
wer nicht geschauspielert habe gespielt
heterosexuelle Männer das war auch der
Tatsache geschuldet das werde ich ein
homosexuellen Mann gespielt hätte in
einer Serie in einem Film wäre mir das
wahrscheinlich um die Ohren geflogen
anscheinend habe ich diese
heterosexuellen Männer glaubhaft
verkörpert also warum sollte umgekehrt
nicht auch ein heterosexueller einen
schwulen spielen dürfen und auch können
oder ich gehe sogar so weit zu sagen
warum sollte ein Mann keine Frau spielen
können also das muss schon alles noch
möglich bleiben dass ich meine das macht
den Beruf eines Schauspielers aus dass
er sich in nahezu alles hineinversetzen
eine Frau einen Mann spielen wie auch
immer genau die die Frage ist natürlich
warum Geschehen diese Dinge und was
machen Sie mit unserem Bild von der
Realität oder eben auch mit dann
kreativer Kunst sie haben diese
Geschichte erzählt von der Vietnamesen
am Set von also es war das genau um die
Serie Club lasst Piranha irgendwann
laufen wird und meine Wunschvorstellung
war und das Mark tendenziell überholt
sein was ich mir da vorgestellt habe ich
wollte gerne dass eine der
Hauptdarstellerin eine Vietnamesin ist
mit einem starken vietnamesischen Akzent
an deutsch sprechend aber vietnamesisch
da gab es riesen Diskussionen das würde
nicht gehen und diese Vietnamesin müsste
ganz glasklares Deutsch sprechen so als
hätte sie in Hannover studiert wir haben
es dann letztendlich auch so gemacht
aber ich fand schon problematisch dass
wir jetzt in der Darstellung von
Ausländern die in Deutschland leben dazu
übergehen dass diese immer perfekt
deutsch sprechen sollen das das ist
verrückt das ist nicht die Realität so
sehr darf noch fragen wir natürlich für
wen sprechen Frau plain würden sie auch
da sagen das ist problematisch wenn es
eben in den Bereich der Kunst geht weil
wir uns da auch unsere Kreativität
nehmen weil wir uns eine Empathie
Fähigkeit absprechen weil wir weil wir
also ich würde generell nicht sagen dass
nicht weiße Personen in Filmproduktionen
keine Akzente haben dürfen ich würde
aber mal die Frage stellen ist das
wichtig für die Darstellung der Person
ist der Akzent am Ende der Witz ist es
nötig ist vielleicht auch ein Klischee
es ist genau bedientes und auch auf der
anderen Seite man muss das ja auch mal
aus der Seite der Schauspielerinnen
sehen die davon betroffen sind für uns
ist es dann diese eine diese eine
Auseinandersetzung in der wir einer
vietnamesischen Schauspielerin oder
vietnamesisch ständigen Schauspielerin
deutschen Schauspielerin vielleicht mit
deutschen Pass sagen sie soll doch bitte
mit starkem Akzent spielen
Schauspieler in die diesen Minderheiten
angehören in Deutschland kriegen das
weil mehr als jedem zweiten Casting
gesagt und es ist fast immer der Witz ja
dass das
diese Person eben kein richtiges Deutsch
spricht das ist immer die Pointe warum
muss das so sein
weiß ich natürlich aus einem Akzent oder
einem Dialekt auch Wortspiele ergeben
die sich wenn sich zwei
gleichberechtigte gepartner in der
Sprache gegenübersteht einfach nicht
ergeben das ist einer der Gründe und all
das was Sie beschreiben ist richtig die
Gedanken muss man sich machen nur wenn
man sich all diese Gedanken im Vorfeld
einer kreativen Arbeit macht dann landet
man irgendwann dabei dass man
Karteikarten ausfüllt und guckt was habe
ich denn jetzt alles erfüllt und was
nicht und es geht auf Kosten der
Spontanität und es geht auf Kosten der
Kunst mir fällt jetzt auch ehrlich
gesagt im Rückblick nicht wirklich ein
Beispiel ein für ein Film wo ich sage oh
da hat aber jemand etwas gespielt was er
besser nicht hätte tun sollen Tom Hanks
sagt heute dass er in Philadelphia nicht
den AIDS krankgeschrieben hätte spielen
sollen er hat einen Oscar dafür bekommen
ich fand seine Darstellung brillant und
der Film hat auch heute noch seine
Berechtigung so würde kann man denn
heute nicht mehr machen aber als
historische Stück finde ich hat er immer
noch seine Berechtigung Hollywood
verfilmt auch gerade wieder das Leben
von Goldammer ihr und diese
historisch bedeutsame jüdische
Politikerin soll nicht von einer
nichtjüden gespielt werden es gibt
tatsächlich auch in Amerika natürlich
Menschen die das beklagen ähnlich wie
der us-penvorsitzende
und sagt das ist schon problematisch ist
wenn wir Menschen absprechen sich in
andere hineinzuversetzen wie
beispielsweise eben einem großen Kenner
des amerikanischen das US-amerikanischen
Befreiungskampfes der schwarzen der eine
Biografie schreiben wollte und kein
Verlag fast das an weil es wenigstens
war es im Dezember des Jahres 22 so weil
der Autor ein weißer ist also da soll
der weiße Kenner der
Bürgerrechtsbewegung der USA nicht diese
Biographie über Evans schreiben
noch mal die Frage an Wissenschaftler
ist das gut wenn wir so voller Vorsicht
sind auch in künstlerischen Fragen also
ich habe da volles Verständnis für
Sensibilitäten und Rücksichtnahme ja das
war sagt man muss da genau schauen wer
fühlt sich die Stereotypisierung
gekränkt und so weiter aber ich glaube
dass diese Entwicklung in der Tat hoch
gefährlich ist weil wir zum Beispiel
davon ausgehen müssen dass Wissenschaft
etwas ist an ein Unterfangen an dem alle
teilhaben können
unabhängig von ihrer Gemeinschaft
Zugehörigkeit und sie haben mich ja
jetzt als Wissenschaft angesprochen
deswegen erlaube ich mir da so ein
wissenschaftliche Bemerkung es gab in
den 80er Jahren diese kommende
touristische Bewegung in den USA und die
hatte auch sehr gute Gründe zu sagen
naja ihr mit euren Liberalen Weltbild
und Gesellschaftsbild individualistisch
und jeder verwirklicht sich selbst und
so weiter ihr übersät was was ganz
wichtig ist nämlich das wir sind wer wir
sind durch Zugehörigkeit zu
Gemeinschaften
sich als Christ fühlen zu einer
neighbourhood zu gehören oder eben zu
Gemeinschaften zu gehören deren
Vorfahren Sklaven waren ja black
Community ist in den USA und so weiter
und ich habe den Eindruck das ist 80er
Jahre ja eine Korrektur des Liberalismus
die vernünftigeren Vertreter dieser
Richtung immer nur gesagt Korrektur geht
nicht um eine Alternative und jetzt
haben wir so eine Art Überschlag bei der
dieser kommende Tourismus dazu führt
dass dieses du bist
jeweils das
zu der Gemeinschaft zu der du gehörst
dass definiert dich und das ist hoch
gefährlich ist letztlich auch mit der
Demokratie mit Humanismus nicht
vereinbar ich will mal so ein Bild
fassen ja wir leben in der
multikulturellen Gesellschaft ich habe
jetzt eine reale Person vor Augen ja die
ist Türken die ist Muslimen die trinkt
Alkohol die ist Fan von FC Bayern
München ist eine Modebranche tätig ist
alles eine reale Figur das heißt wir
Navigieren durch eine Vielzahl von
kollektiven Identitäten wir sind aber
irgendwie immer die Person die das
aushalten muss auch die
Spannungsverhältnisse auch die
Gegensätze die dadurch entstehen und das
können wir nicht dadurch heilen dass wir
sagen naja wir machen jetzt hier meine
saubere Trennung Aufteilung du bist das
du bist jenes wir sprechen nur über
unsere eigene Themen ihr sprecht nicht
über unsere wer spricht dann über Hartz
IV im Bundestag niemand bezieht
oder Wissenschaft wir können nicht mehr
über afrikanische Geschichte schreiben
weil wir selber nicht dazu gehören das
ist nicht gut aber ich finde auch nicht
gut dass so getan wird als wenn es um
betroffenheitskuld gehen würde es geht
um Erfahrungswirklichkeit und wenn wir
beim Thema Kunst sind können wir das
konkretisieren ich glaube der Moment wo
Eigenschaften an Nationalität und
Religion gekoppelt werden da wird es
natürlich gefährlich da sind wir beim
Kampf der Kulturen von Samuel Huntington
und das ist ja auch das worauf zum
Beispiel rechtsextreme ihre Politik
sozusagen daraus ableiten aber natürlich
macht es einen Unterschied ob Francis
von Kopf oder den Partner gedreht hat
das hat den Washington gesagt nicht ich
zitiere ihn oder Wesley Snipes schwarze
macht oder ich meinetwegen als sie den
Dokumentarfilm über den Völkermarkt
Religionsgemeinschaft und ganz ehrlich
wenn ich nicht die Möglichkeit bekommen
hätte hätte mir das weh getan und das
hat keine egoistischen Gründe sondern
ich bin der festen Überzeugung dass
unsere Sozialisation unserer
Erfahrungswerte das tiefe wissen was man
nicht studieren kann an keiner Uni
dieser Welt mit hineinfließen sollen und
deswegen geht es hier um Repräsentanz
und wenn ich an meine deutschen
schauspielerfreundinnen und Freunde
denke viele von ihnen haben
zuwendungsgeschichte die sind es leid
die sind das Leid darüber gesprochene
Stereotype zu bedienen vom Terroristen
vom Intensivstraftäter dies war die es
gibt auf jeden Fall gibt es die also ich
will jetzt nicht so tun als wenn es das
nicht gibt wir müssen uns immer in der
Lebenswirklichkeit orientieren auch bei
diesem Thema aber eben nicht nur und
nicht ausschließlich und wenn wir dieses
Bild aber nähern so wie in den letzten
Jahrzehnten dann entsteht eben auch ein
Gefühl und ich kann mich daran erinnern
auch als Redakteurin für ein großes
Medienunternehmen für das ich gearbeitet
habe das ist natürlich auch ich Probleme
arbeiten musste und dadurch immer
Figuren auch zustande gekommen sind die
problematisch waren und ich habe immer
die Frage gestellt nach dem
Gegenbeispiel und dann ist es immer nee
brauchen wir nicht und heute sehe ich
das anders ich glaube wir brauchen das
Gegenbeispiel das ist ja auch der Grund
warum ich eine ganze Bildungsinitiative
Germany deswegen gegründet habe und da
finde ich müssen wir einfach ein
bisschen ehrlicher werden und dieser
diskuss muss erweitert werden ich sehe
es genauso wie sie wenn nur noch wir
über uns reden dürfen dann werden wir
ziemlich allein gelassen also ich möchte
eine solidarische Gesellschaft ich will
dass ich ein alter
voneinander war ich will das alle
Menschen sich für uns einsetzen und und
mit der richtigen Einstellung daran
gehen und uns verteidigen das wünsche
ich mir und ganz viele Menschen die ich
kenne wünschen sich das aber auch aber
in dem Moment wo wir Menschen auch
weißen Menschen absprechen über
bestimmte Themen zu reden ist das auch
kennenzul Kaltschaum also ich finde da
müssen wir einfach ehrlicher sein aber
auf der anderen Seite wie gesagt geht es
um Identität es geht um Schmerz es geht
um Wut der Jahrzehnte lang unterdrückt
worden ist und dass wir heute sagen
indigene Völker statt das Wort zu
benutzen hat was damit zu tun dass uns
was beigebracht worden ist aus der
Community und ich glaube es muss mehr
ums Zuhören gehen auch beim Thema so und
jetzt sind wir in der Realität und nicht
mehr in der Kunst und unbedingt noch
Leonie ja ich wollte dazu noch
hinzufügen das ja also gehen gerade
darum dass wir uns in diesem Gruppen
dann irgendwie abschotten dass das
identitätsstiftend ist aber durch
Stereotype wird ja von anderen eine
Identität auferlegt und darüber haben
dann Betroffene marginalisierter Gruppen
mitgliedermaginalisierter Gruppen eben
keine Kontrolle mehr dazu sprachen sie
gerade davon dass es um Befindlichkeiten
geht aber es geht ja nicht nur um
Befindlichkeiten sondern klar natürlich
wenn jemand vielfeindlich transfeindlich
rassistisch mysogün ist wird in dem
Moment auch eine persönliche
Empfindlichkeit getroffen vor allem aber
wird ein ein ganzes System der
Unterdrückung aufrecht erhalten unter
dem alle ja alle Menschen aus dieser
Community leiden
ja und damit sind wir dann bei der Frage
wie es zu der känzel culture kommt und
auch da gibt es eine Menge zu verstehen
also es gibt Menschen die haben Angst
vor sprachverboten und vor einer gender
Polizei oder sie tun auch nur so
mit jeder geänderten Nachrichtensendung
gehen ein paar hundert Stimmen mehr zur
AFD
die macher:innen erklärten leider können
wir unsere Überzeugung nicht mehr Angst
frei in die Tat umsetzen
es herrscht Krieg in Deutschland nur ein
verbaler Gott sei Dank Obst aller und
Butter sei auch krank und natürlich auch
allen Atheistinnen
[Musik]
Worte erregen die Gemüter das N-Wort der
Klassiker lupenrein rassistisch und
gerade deshalb so beliebt bei
Feinschmeckern der Provokation
anderswo im deutschen Vokabular wirds
kniffliger sollte die Mohrenstraße in
Berlin-Mitte umbenannt werden
darf man Zigeunerschnitzel bestellen und
darf man das selber entscheiden
schließlich gibt es keine gültigen
Vorschriften er Politiker die gern einen
Popanz aufbauen um darauf einzudreschen
im Fernsehen wird ber
ichtet die islamistinnen ziehen immer
mehr in afghanische Städte ein
also so richtig viel weibliche Taliban
habe ich noch nicht gesehen Eltern
werden künftig anders gelandet Mutter
und Vater werden zu Elternteil 1 und
Elternteil zwei der Angler heißt künftig
die fischangelnde Person die Muttermilch
wird zur Menschen oder elternmilch liebe
Freunde sorry haben wir in unserem Land
nicht wirklich wichtigere Probleme als
solche lächerlichen Ideen wir haben
bestimmt wichtigere Probleme unter Söder
treibt es da auf die Spitze reden wir
auch gleich noch drüber warum das so
attraktiv ist aber erstmal die Frage
diesen Tacker warum ist es für Boris
Palmer einen extra Kampf Wert dieses
endwort aussprechen zu können warum
pocht Peter hane darauf weiter
Zigeunerschnitzel sagen zu dürfen ist es
trotzdem sie haben selber angesprochen
ja weil ihm der Beifall dann sicher ist
und der Applaus also wir leben in Zeiten
wo wir von 20% AFD sprechen und das hat
nichts mit der Bildungspolitik zu tun
dieser Partei sondern dieses
ausschließlich gebaut auf
Islamfeindlichkeit und
Ausländerfeindlichkeit und wir wissen
als Menschenrechtsaktivisten die auf der
Asche des Völkermords unserer
Religionsgemeinschaft entstanden sind
das Krisen Sündenböcke kreieren und das
ist gefährlicher Populismus der dort
betrieben wird das sind Vorurteile die
sozusagen hochgesprochen werden und
damit wird dann Politik gemacht das ist
das was ich Kriegsführer häufig zu Nutze
machen denn die Frage ist ja wie
entstehen Kriege und völkermode sie
entstehen durch Feindbilder so und
deswegen glaube ich auch wenn Sprache
nicht das Wichtigste ist zumindest nicht
in unserer Arbeit ja also unsere
Lebenswirklichkeit findet nicht im
Internet statt sondern vor Ort on the
round in den Regionen ist es trotzdem
wichtig zu sagen das kenzel kaltscher
tödlich ist und es wird oft behauptet
dass das aus linksliberaler Ecke Ecken
kommt ja das stimmt aber eben nicht
ausschließlich die Kennzahlen die aus
rechtsextreme Ecke kommt die tötet
Menschen siehe Walter Lübcke siehe NSU
sehe die Flüchtlingsunterkünfte die dann
auch in Brand gesetzt werden und da
glaube ich das mer auch an unserer
tagtäglichen Arbeit der Shitstorm ist
eigentlich permanent als Damoklesschwert
schwebt er über uns und warum weil wir
den Antisemitismus bekämpfen den
Islamismus den Rassismus und den
Sexismus und das heute in Deutschland zu
tun bedarf auch einer gründlichen
Überprüfung aber wenn wir das nicht tun
würden wenn wir uns das nicht trauen
würden dann würde ich dir heute auch
nicht sitzen das heißt wir müssen genau
hinhören auf der einen Seite müssen wir
diese ist mit aller vehements und null
Toleranz bekämpfen aber nicht jede
Meinung die mir nicht passt ist
Volksverhetzung also auch das ist noch
mal wichtig so und jetzt kann man es
noch weiter runterbrechen ihre Eltern
ihre Familie kommt aus dem kurdischen
Teil der Türkei genau verstehen ihre
Eltern wenn sie denen sagen dass es
besser jetzt nicht mehr das
Zigeunerschnitzel ist was sie also ich
glaube das ist ein ganz wichtiges
Beispiel was zeigt dass die Trennlinien
hier nicht zwischen auch Hochton Deutsch
und Migranten verlaufen das ist
selbstverständlich Geschichte haben
davon auch mit betroffen sind und dass
sie auch in dem lern ist jetzt
selbstverständlich haben wir früher
andere Wörter benutzt als wir das heute
machen würden und auch wir werden anders
hinterfragt und gechallenged von von
meinen Nichten beispielsweise als wir
das gemacht haben und ich habe es vorhin
Vorgespräch gesagt so habe keine wir
sind mit seinen Witzen aufgewachsen als
ganze Familie haben wir uns schlapp und
kaputt gelacht und ich glaube das
Besondere bei bei ihnen ist einfach auch
dass die Figuren dass die liebevoll
behandelt worden sind und dass man nie
den Eindruck hatte dass da eine
Abwertung stattfindet also das geht ja
darum zwischen den Zeilen auch
tatsächlich zu lesen und natürlich ist
das sozusagen ein fortwährender Prozess
und auch unsere heile Welt und deswegen
mussten wir ja sprechfähig werden wurde
immer von allen Seiten bedroht nicht nur
von auch tun deutscher Seite sondern in
der Schule wenn ich gesagt habe dass ich
Kohle bin dann wurde gefragt wo ist denn
Kurdistan ja das haben mich nicht die
deutschen Kinder gefragt ja und wenn ich
gesagt habe ich bin die sie denn dann
hat man gesagt du bist eine Ungläubige
das hatten die zu Hause gelernt
teilweise und wenn dann z.B ist ein Buch
geht wie Timm Thaler von James Krüss wo
unsere Religionsgemeinschaft als Teufel
später bezeichnet wird ja interessant
zum Beispiel dann muss man heutzutage
darüber reden dann wünsche ich mir nicht
das ist gestrichen wird das Buch soll so
bleiben wie es war aber ich würde mir
wünschen dass man sozusagen eine
Quellenangabe daneben aufmacht und
erklärt warum das so sagen keine
teufelsanbindung genau das meine ich das
ist so ein Beispiel und ich glaube es
geht auch immer darum diesen
Zusammenhang worüber reden wir und das
sind viele heiße Eisen aber ich glaube
schon dass dir das kurz sich verengt hat
das ist ein Thema das ist eine ehrlich
machen und das viele Menschen
mittlerweile die Faust in der Tasche
Ballen und sagen ich sag meine Meinung
nicht aus Angst was falsches zu sagen
und da muss ich an Wolf Biermann dann
denken das ist um um die Schläge geht
die wir nicht austeilen wie lange wir
das machen wollen also im besten Sinne
deswegen werde ich für Streitkultur und
kurz sind jetzt gleich ganz viele
Gedanken danke dafür und wir sind bei
der Frage nach dem Wort habe Kerkeling
da sind
sie nicht als Abgeordnete im
parlamentarisch
vielleicht morgen und übermorgen ein
Wort der würde sich eine Mehrheit sofort
verständigen dass das nicht zu brauchen
ist bei Indianer wäre es schon nicht
mehr so schnell herstellbar dass man da
jetzt von indigenen spricht und mit
welcher Konsequenz eben auch auf die
Bücher und die Filme in denen auf die
wir zurückgreifen
da öffnet sich natürlich wirklich die
große Farbe sollen wir das jetzt
verändern sollen Bücher umgeschrieben
werden sollen Filme oder erzählt werden
Fragezeichen also wenn man dieser
Diskussion die bis jetzt geführt wurde
zuhört und nicht weiß in welcher
Gesellschaft wir heute leben müsste man
annehmen dass wir auf dem besten Wege
sind so eine Art liberales Paradies zu
schaffen besseres Wort fällt mir jetzt
nicht ein das Gegenteil ist aber der
Fall
wir versuchen
Gleichberechtigung an vielen Stellen
gleichzeitig und das völlig zu Recht
umzusetzen erleben aber dass so eine
rechtsradikale Partei wie die AFD jetzt
bei 30 Prozent steht wie hängt das
zusammen das eine befördert nicht das
andere und was Söder da sagt ist
durchweg polemisch und eigentlich auch
nicht annehmbar und geht schon in die
radikale Richtung nichtsdestotrotz finde
ich sollte man gemächlichen Schritt des
vorangehen bei all diesen Änderungen und
versuchen so viele Menschen wie möglich
auf diesem Weg mitzunehmen und jetzt
radikal an Astrid Lindgren Rand zu gehen
und Takatukaland umzubenennen das ist
glaube ich alles wenig hilfreich ich
glaube schon dass Menschen verstehen was
der Hintergrund dieser dieser Idee ist
aber ich glaube man muss das alles etwas
langsamer angehen und tatsächlich finde
ich es auch befremdlich wenn ich jetzt
an jedes Wort innen hängen muss das
erleben Sie auch nur in Deutschland so
das gibt es in England nicht gibt es in
den Niederlanden und in Italien nicht
und ich frage mich für Menschen die nach
Deutschland kommen
die zuwandern denen wollen wir
beibringen dass sie nach einem
Doppelpunkt auch noch das innen setzen
wollen das meine ich jetzt gar nicht
polemisch sondern einfach auch aus
praktischen Erwägungen und so eine
Sprache sollte auch schön sein und ich
finde es einfach nicht schön und damit
sind wir auf der geographisch linken
Seite und fangen bei Leonie Plan an und
sagen würden sie wichtig und richtig
finden dass man eben nicht nur in
Kinderbüchern sondern auch in
Erwachsenen Literatur diese
Veränderungen vornimmt oder trauen wir
den deutschen und überhaupt im
Weltbürger zu dass er auch mit einer
Fußnote gut was anfangen kann das nicht
tatsächlich differenziert also im
Kinderbüchern bin ich absolut für die
Streichung rassistischer Begriffe weil
gerade wenn wir über Pippi Langstrumpf
über Karlsson vom Dach reden das wird
der Kindern in einem Alter vor allem
vorgelesen oder Kinder lesen das in
einem Alter indem sie sich noch gar
nicht der Geschichte und dem Ausmaß
dieser Wörter Bewusstsein können
und was wir dadurch machen indem wir
diese Worte darin lassen ist dass wir
diese Begriffe für Kinder normalisieren
die sagen das sind auf dem Schulhof und
es ist völlig normal aber die Kinder die
von Rassismus betroffen sind die trifft
es dann und die trifft das hart und ich
meine wir diskutieren jetzt hier über
das Wort über das evolut über das
Zeitwort und es sitzt niemand der
Betroffenen mit einem Tisch das ist halt
auch symptomatisch für diese für den
Kreis hier springen aber wir sind
ich fand es gerade auch sehr spannend
also zum einen davon von Verboten zu
sprechen finde ich sehr spannend weil
wir haben ja diese Worte gerade im
Beitrag alle ausgesprochen und
ausgeschrieben gesehen so schlimm kann
also die verbotskultur rund um diese
Begriffe noch nicht sein
was das sind noch mal zur Frage wie geht
man damit in Erwachsenen Literatur um
also würden Sie sagen nicht nur
Kinderbücher und nicht nur Astrid
Lindgren sondern auch in Erwachsenen
Literatur oder trauen wir uns die
Fußnote in Erwachsenenliteratur sehe ich
das ein bisschen differenzierter ich
komme ja aus den amerikanischen Studien
und da habe ich natürlich gerade mit der
schwarzen experience in den USA auch in
der Forschung viel zu tun gehabt
da bin ich bei einem Buch wie uncle
Tom's Kevin absolut dafür dass drin zu
lassen weil da genau
weil da die Schlagkraft dieses Wortes
auch aus dem Kontext heraus klar wird
und in vielen Ausgaben haben wir
trotzdem noch diese Fußnote oder ein
Vorwort in dem man steht hier wird
dieser Begriff vorkommen das ist was er
bedeutet aber das ist eben eine Form von
Literatur die ich nicht lesen kann ohne
mich mit der Bedeutung und mit der
Schlagkraft dieses Wortes
auseinanderzusetzen und gleich noch mal
dann auch die Genderfrage hier aber
erstmal Herr niederrömelin was würden
Sie sagen kann man es mit der
Sensibilität da übertreiben oder ist es
gut auch bei Erwachsenen Literatur so
differenziert heute noch mal zu schauen
ob Menschen diskriminiert werden also
mit Sensibilitäten kann man es
eigentlich nie übertreiben ja Rücksicht
nehmen auf bestimmte Gefühlslagen auf
Empfindsamkeiten und so weiter ist ein
ganz wichtige Grundhaltung
aber das was sie indirekt schon
angesprochen haben da lohnt sich noch
mal genauer Anblick drauf
Aufmerksamkeit da ja aber es ist schon
ein ganz wesentlicher Aspekt also wir
haben in USA viel stärker als in Europa
wir haben das Phänomen das sind
bestimmten akademischen Milieus an der
auf den College ist und Universität
Campus da werden alle möglichen
Überlegungen angestellt wie die Sprache
so modifizieren kann dass also eben
Empfindlichkeiten eben nicht auftreten
können und man Rücksicht nimmt und so
Großteil der Bevölkerung hat mal
irgendwann die Schule besucht und ist
mit Mühe und Not da durchgekommen und
erinnert sich noch vage an
Grammatikregeln und hat dann den
Eindruck sind wir eigentlich mitgemeint
wir sind irgendwie mit gemeint wir
müssten das ja eigentlich mitmachen wir
verstehen gar nicht was genau jetzt
wieder der neueste Stand ist der Debatte
ist es in Ordnung Sternchen zu machen
oder Doppelpunkt oder großes i und so
weiter und da entsteht ein klassischen
sie sind amerikanistin also eine Art
Klassenstruktur die viele Leute so
empfinden wir sind nicht dabei wir sind
nicht mit gemeint und das nutzen dann
Rechtspopulisten für Ihre Kampagnen und
das ist nicht ungefährlich insofern gibt
es einen Zusammenhang so ungeschickt das
in diesem Zitat von Metz von März
rübergekommen ist aber es gibt da einen
Zusammenhang diese dieses Gefühl wir
sind dabei die duettieren etwas was wir
gar nicht verstehen und wir sind dauern
sozusagen Leute die hinterherlaufen
müssen führt dann dazu dass die
traditionelle Wählerschaft linker
Parteien unterdessen zu großen Teilen
rechtswelt wir sind bei der Frage ganz
praktisch Düsen wie machen sie das also
gerade Gendern entschuldigung da gibt es
Doppelpunkt Pause sprechen Sternchen
sprechen wie machen sie das persönlich
ich mache das mit dem binneni
beispielsweise und das ist immer sehr
intuitiv bei mir aber in unserer
Menschenrechtsorganisation wird mit dem
Doppelpunkt gearbeitet und das hat
natürlich auch was mit der
Zusammensetzung der Menschen zu tun also
wir sind da keine Partei sondern wir
sind von vornherein intersektional
gewesen und zwar nicht weil wir
politisch korrekt sein wollen weil wir
alle an einem Tisch bringen wollen und
ich glaube tatsächlich auch dass viele
Menschen sich in dem Zusammenhang das
Thema ist heute die Frage stellen ist
das das Wichtigste was wir besprechen
müssen und da habe ich oft das Gefühl
wenn wir die Probleme noch konkreter
lösen würden wie beispielsweise in einer
diversen Gesellschaft wo jeder vier
U-Bahn und Geschichte hat und wo es
natürlich auch neben dem Reichtum auch
um Herausforderungen geht und wo wir uns
auch Gedanken machen müssen wie wir
beispielsweise mit religiösen
Extremisten umgehen genauso wie wir mit
Rassisten umgehen wenn wir das
adressieren würden wenn wir da keine
Maulkörbe auferlegen würden dann bin ich
davon überzeugt dass die
rechtsextremen Parteien auch weniger
Zulauf hätten also ich glaube auch da
können wir uns und müssen wir uns mehr
zumuten wir müssen über die Probleme
konkreter reden und ich merke auch bei
unserer Menschenrechtsarbeit vor Ort
wenn dann so Sätze fallen wie nieder mit
dem Patriarchat damit komme ich im Irak
noch nicht mal durch die Tür wir haben
aber Frauenhäuser da so die Frage ist
also wirklich wie können wir Probleme
lösen und mich stören dann die
schwarz-weiß Debatten sondern ich muss
in diese Grautöne gehen ich ich kann
dich auf diese hottig sozusagen greifen
damit zerstöre ich dann Projekte und das
ist glaube ich etwas was auch wichtig
ist wie wir diese spaltungsdynamiken
überwinden und Sprache ist wichtig aber
in meiner tagtäglichen Arbeit ist es
nicht das allerwichtigste sondern es
geht auch beispielsweise um die
Bekämpfung von Gewalt an Frauen und
tatsächlich glaube ich eben auch dass es
darum geht wie wir auf dieses Thema
gucken klar und dennoch wieder ganz
praktisch einmal zurückgeschaut weil es
auch Sinn macht dass so gründlich zu
besprechen warum ausgerechnet auf das
Gendern so aggressiv reagiert wird und
warum das so ein Kulturkampf wird mal
jenseits dieser ganz praktischen Frage
ob es eben in jedem Satz mitgesprochen
werden muss mit gefühlt mit geatmet
werden muss und eben traditions- und
praktikabilitätsgründe gibt zu sagen ist
nicht so schön wenn man da irgendwie
immer eine Pause wird das mal in
Klammern warum ist es denn so
erfolgreich daraus einen Kulturkampf zu
machen und wer hat damit angefangen
glauben sie
naja angefangen wenn man ganz
zurückgehen möchten haben im aktuellen
Diskurs damit die amerikanischen rechten
die diesen diesen kulturkampfgeschlecht
in den letzten Jahren sehr erfolgreich
aufgemacht haben jetzt haben sich die
deutschen Konservativen und rechten
davon einiges abgeguckt ich sehe das ein
bisschen anders als Herr März ich bin
der festen Überzeugung wer sich aufgrund
eines Schriftzeichens nach
rechtsradikalisiert für den hätte es das
Schriftzeichen nicht gebraucht
ich persönlich gendere in meinem Alltag
ich gender mit Sternchen weil ich ja die
Lebensrealitäten von nicht mineren
Personen kenne weil ich in einer
Beziehung mit einer nicht wenigeren
Person bin das ist für mich völlig
selbstverständlich und auch einfach
Gewohnheitssache und was ich so spannend
finde ist das ausgerechnet bei diesem
Thema und wir haben ja alle
Geschlechtsidentitäten in allen sozialen
Schichten dann ausgerechnet bestimmte
soziale Schichten in diesen Diskurs
gehabt werden genau oder migrantische
Gruppen für die das eine besondere
Herausforderung darstellen soll also
Menschen in allen sozialen Schichten
sind von transfeindlichkeit von
misogonie von Sexismus überall betroffen
in unseren sozialen
schichtenfeindlichkeit genau den unteren
sozialen Schichten sogar noch mehr als
in anderen weil da eben weniger Privileg
vorher hat und wer schafft die deutsche
Sprache die extrem schwere deutsche
Sprache mit drei Artikeln als
Fremdsprache zu lernen den traue ich
auch das zu tun
die beiden Omis bei Ihnen zu Hause zum
Gendern gesagt
ich glaube die hat gesagt wir probieren
das mal aus ich finde auch vernünftig
dass wir es ausprobieren ob es dabei
bleibt wird man sehen aber es schafft
Bewusstsein es schafft Bewusstsein dafür
dass wir über viele Jahre
Diskriminierung von Frauen hatten diese
Debatte schafft Bewusstsein dafür dass
wir systemischen Rassismus über viele
Jahrzehnte hatten und deswegen ist das
gesund und richtig dass wir diese
Debatte führen und ich glaube das also
das was März gesagt hat ich kann das nur
unterstreichen also wer deswegen AFD
will dem ist nicht zu helfen so und wir
sind noch mal bei der Frage warum ist so
attraktiv ist gerade für die
konservative in Teilen haben sie damit
schon begonnen Handy wieder darüber
liegen darauf zugreifen und zu sagen
daraus machen wir jetzt einen
Kulturkampf es ist ein identitärer Kampf
der im Grunde ja von beiden Seiten um
Identität geführt wird was ist der
historische Hintergrund warum macht man
das ich habe jetzt ein ganzes Buch
geschrieben über dieses Thema deswegen
muss ich mich da sehr beherrschen dass
er kurz zu machen es geht darum dass
cancel culture ist ja hoch umkämpfter
ideologischer Begriff den gibt es zwar
erst seit 2018 seit 2019 ist es dann
nach Europa gekommen tatsächlich ist es
so in der Kulturgeschichte ist cancel
culture der Normalfall a wondere
gewissermaßen bevor dieser Terminus
aufgekommen ist
habe da auch ganze Reihe von Beispielen
dazu genannt Antike
wunderbare Beispiele aber die Demokratie
ist nicht der Normalfall und die
Demokratie beruht auf dieser radikalen
Idee der Aufklärung nämlich dass man
sagt wir wollen alle Meinungen hören es
geht nicht um
streitkulturprinzipien sondern es geht
um die Frage wer hat welche Gründe für
welche Auffassung und wir gehen
respektvoll damit um das ist nicht
selbstverständlich weil das ja mit den
eigenen politischen Interessen oft
kollidiert ich habe ein Interesse daran
dass bestimmte Meinungen im Diskurs
nicht auftauchen und dann zu sagen
berühmtes Zitat ich kämpfe dafür dass
diese Meinung die ich lieber nicht hören
würde eine Rolle spielen darf das ist
Basis der Demokratie und deswegen wollte
ich da mal genau hinschauen und sagen
das hat nichts mit rechts und links zu
tun cancel culture gibt es in rechten
Varianten den linken Varianten im
mittleren Varianten darum geht es
überhaupt nicht sondern es geht um die
Praxis in der Demokrat Offenheit in der
Demokratie der Offenheit des Respekts
der Anerkennung von Unterschiedlichkeit
Menschenwürde steht in unserer
Verfassung ganz vorne und ich
unterscheide drei Kategorien von cancel
culture die erste ist ich will bestimmte
Meinungen nicht hören die sollen in dem
Diskurs nicht vorkommen wir müssen uns
überlegen wie wir die plattforming wie
das manche nennen die müssen von den
Plattform runter oder wir wollen ganze
Personen die Meinungen äußern die uns
nicht passen Häresie Mittelalter und
frühen Neuzeit aber genau das findet
jetzt auch statt die wollen wir nicht
mehr hören ja und das dritte ist
natürlich das Schlimmste in vielen
Regionen der Welt wir vernichten diese
Person physisch oder so Kanal oder
beruflich das heißt ja es geht dann auf
die ganze Person und das glaube ich
diese Praxis so verführerisch sie ist
aus politischen Gründen zu sagen wir
haben doch Möglichkeiten wir haben
Einflussmöglichkeiten wir können die
wegdrücken und so ist für die
Demokratieentwicklung hochgefährlich und
nochmal die der Gedanke von Hape
Kerkeling eigentlich werden die Gesetze
in unserem Land und nicht nur in unserem
Land immer liberale aber die Reaktion
der Menschen wird immer radikaler das
hat nicht nur keinen Zusammenhang
sondern der ist natürlich die Wahl was
tut man in dieser Zeit der Transition
also was tut man wenn wir eigentlich
merken man kann zwei schwule dürfen
heiraten und sie verpachten nicht nur
sondern sie dürfen heiraten aber Sie
werden viel häufiger zusammengeschlagen
also das gilt nicht in allen westlichen
Demokratien wir haben in den USA
gegenwärtig massiven backlash das heißt
die Gesetzgebung dort knüpft wieder an
an den 50er Jahren wir haben auch ein
paar Beispiele schon genannt und ich
würde mal generell sagen allen linken
und linksliberalen die meisten sind
Wirklichkeit kommilitaristen sind ohne
es zu wissen würde ich sagen
alle Entschuldigung Kommunitarismus war
das die Gemeinschaft dass die
Gemeinschaft zugehörig das ist
entscheidend Position primär sondern
kommissaristische würde ich sagen
Vorsicht fast alles können die Rechten
auch die können auch identity politiks
betreiben die können auch sagen wir sind
eben was besonderes und wir
identifizieren uns natürlich mit
Diskriminierung mit ganz anderen
gefährlichen Strategien aber das
Switch dann um was der dezantis im
Florida macht ja ist genau staatlich
organisierte
transländer Personen dürfen nicht
auftreten in Schulen Literatur wird
verboten an den Schulen und so weiter
hat es aber auch eigentlich schon
gegeben in der mccasi Zeit genau auch da
seine Wiederaufnahme eigentlich ich ja
unter anderem Vorzeichen
selbstverständlich die da jetzt kommt
und ich würde sagen der Staat Menschen
verfolgt die anderer progressive
ideologische Auffassung waren wird
trotzdem nochmal begrifflich
unterscheiden Staat das ist dann Zensur
oder auch über Gesetzgebung eben Verbote
und so weiter publikationsverbote cancel
culture ist mehr das ist eine Kultur des
Umgangs mit abweichenden Meinungen und
wenn diese Kultur entsprechend rigide
ist irgendwann nutzt das die Politik und
setzt das dann entsprechend in
zensurpraktiken und so weiter um also da
gibt es sie sind ein wirklich scharfer
Analytiker alle drei sind Schafe
analytika mich würde interessieren mich
würde interessieren haben sie eine
Prognose wo wir in zehn Jahren stehen
werden wo die bundesrepublikanische
Gesellschaft
ausgehend von der heutigen Situation wo
das hinläuft ja schwierig zu sagen
wenn man mal die drei großen Vorbilder
von Demokratie Frankreich 1789 USA
ungefähr dieselbe Zeit dann
Großbritannien an sich anschaut dass
gerade diese vorbilddemokratie wieder
haben gesagt das ist britische
kaminsensorientierte Demokratie
zivilkultur und so ausgerechnet die sind
in einer tiefen Krise und wir haben
immer wieder das Phänomen dass das was
in den USA vor allem passiert dann bei
uns nachgeholt wird oft in einer
albernen Variante aber wir armen vieles
nach dann würde ich erstmal Pessimist
sein also die Situation in den USA sind
sie auch Experte nicht war aber da auch
Gastprofessor und so schon in den 90er
Jahren habe ich dann Gottes Willen das
läuft in die falsche Richtung von daher
Pessimismus andererseits glaube ich dass
diese Faszination für den
Rechtspopulismus ist eine der Bedrohung
nicht die einzige dass die abklingen
wird in dem Moment wo klar ist wir
brauchen Lösungen für konkrete Probleme
und die Nutzen im Grunde unzufrieden
Gelegenheit nicht dazugehörig fühlen und
sowas jetzt im Osten auch aus um halt
Propaganda zu machen aber dahinter ist
keine Substanz das sind meine Hoffnung
und das vielleicht in paar Jahren wieder
vorbei diese Form von Bedrohung so und
eigentlich gibt es ja auch genug
konkrete Lösungen und hier an dem Tisch
auch schon genug konkrete Ansätze und
vielleicht gehen wir noch mal auf diesen
Aspekt den ich darüber liegen gerade
gefragt habe wie man heute eigentlich in
der Gesellschaft mit diesem Widerspruch
klar kommt das ist die jure eine viel
liberalere
Gesetzgebung gibt und auf der anderen
Seite die Radikalität auf den Straßen
gewachsen ist ich davon ihnen erzählen
dass sie mit ihrem Mann von Berlin nach
Bonn gezogen sind und der Grund war
tatsächlich auch die Situation hier in
Berlin die Atmosphäre ist deutlich
homophober geworden ja und
dementsprechend haben wir uns dafür
entschieden Berlin schweren Herzens zu
verlassen und nach Köln zurückzugehen
was wir auch bisher nicht bereut haben
ich habe aber manchmal das Gefühl ich
bin keine Historiker aber dass wir in
einer ähnlichen Zeit leben doch wie in
der Weimarer Republik auch da gab es
doch diese diesen Fortschritt es gab
Magnus Hirschfeld ist es war kein
Problem Transgender zu sein es gab erste
Geschlechtsumwandlung alles das war
völlig unproblematisch Anfang der 20er
Jahre es gab sogar die Idee für ein
verpartnerungsgesetz auch das gab es
schon in der weimarerelle Republik sind
wir in so einer ähnlichen Situation das
frag ich mich manchmal bekommt es so vor
als wären wir am Vorabend von etwas was
ich jetzt nicht dringend erleben möchte
also das war ja auch damals dass das
markus hirschfelds-institut war ja eins
der ersten Institute das von den
Nationalsozialisten niedergebrannt wurde
gerade dieser also gerade dieser Aspekt
wird ja in der in der historischen
Forschung auch viel übersehen dass wir
fangen ja jetzt überhaupt erst wirklich
an die Geschichte der Verfolgung von
queren und trans-menschen in der NS-Zeit
überhaupt überhaupt aufzuarbeiten aber
ja es war natürlich ein riesengroßer
Faktor natürlich ist es nicht eins zu
eins vergleichbar aber die die Kämpfe
werden wieder aufgemacht und wir hatten
jetzt gerade von paar Tagen ein ein
Kampagnenbild der AFD Sachsen in der sie
den den rosa Winkel mit der Pride Flagge
hinterlegt haben also schon eine ganz
explizite Nutzung von
nationalsozialistischen Symbolen um die
lgbtqai+ Community anzugreifen und dann
ist ja der nächste die nächste logische
Frage was wird das für sie bedeuten
bedeutet das für sie zu sagen wir müssen
das unbedingt weitermachen unser Kampf
um eine liberalere kenntnisreichere
bunkere also aufmerksame Sprache ist
immer noch das wichtigste auch wenn die
Verhältnisse noch schlechter werden
entschuldigung wenn ich das so Frage
naja also für mich war es auf jeden Fall
also in meiner partnerinschaft war es
schon Thema wir hatten schon die
Gespräche wo gehen wir hin wenn
Deutschland nicht mehr sicher ist jetzt
bin ich in der deutschen
Mehrheitsgesellschaft noch ein
akzeptables Bild von lesbisch ja es
würde ganz anders aussehen ja es wurde
ganz anders aussehen phänotypisch
privilegiert tatsächlich genau es würde
ganz anders aussehen wenn hier eine
maskulin präsentierende schwarze
genderkiere Butch lässt besitzen würde
dann hätten wir ein ganz anderen Diskurs
und das sind ja also aber wir können die
uns vorstellen wir können uns die
vorstellen das sind die sind natürlich
die Menschen innerhalb unserer Community
die gerade am meisten und als
allererstes darunter leiden und auch das
war historische und so historisch haben
Trans Personen Trans Personen auf color
für unsere rechte Art vorderster Fronten
und gerade jetzt ist es an uns diese
Fackel weiter zu tragen und diese
schlechten Lieder in unserer Kette zu
schützen aber ja wir hatten auf jeden
Fall diese Diskussion schon diese Kampf
in der Ersatz werden ist meine Frage
also wenn man sich jetzt so auf die
Sprache konzentriert und auch inkludiert
das da vielleicht viele gar nicht
mitkommen und das ist einen wahnsinnigen
Protest und Revolte will ich jetzt nicht
geben sagen aber eben erst mal einen
Protest dagegen kann das zu einer
Ersatzhandlung verkommen sich so auf die
Sprache zu konzentrieren naja
tatsächlich konzentrieren wir
aktivistischen stimmen uns ja gar nicht
so sehr auf die Sprache einfach ich
fordere wieder eine genderpflicht ja
noch noch zwingend ich das irgendwie auf
ich mache das einfach in meinem
täglichen Sprachgebrauch und in meinem
täglichen Schrift Gebrauch und damit es
gut da sind mit sind dann auch alle
Menschen mit gemeint die sich in meine
Community befinden und dafür damit ist
das Thema für mich beendet das ist auch
komplette Gewohnheitssache inzwischen
stolper ich eher darüber wenn ich das
generische Maskulinum höre deswegen ist
niemandem auf gleichzeitig wenn wir über
sprach Polizei
ändern sondern ich meine tatsächlich
auch das politische genau politisch
korrekt sprechen dieses Gefühl auch
schon themaisiert dass die Leute in noch
nicht der mehr heit aber zu 48 % in
diesem Land sagen dass sie nicht mehr
sprechen können was sie denken aber
machen Sie erstmal den Gedanken
entschuldigung ich wollte nur sagen so
gleichzeitig haben wir von rechts
konkrete Verbote dass Länder also in
vier Bundesländern mindestens ist das
Gendern landesweit verboten in Schulen
oder in den Landesbehörden es hat
teilweise die AFD zusammen mit der CDU
durchgebracht in Thüringen
generell redet sowieso niemand so viel
übers Gendern wie Rechte und
konservative denn tatsächlich ist es ja
eine Nebelkerze es ist was was irgendwie
worüber sich alle irgendwie aufregen
können ohne besonders viel Ahnung davon
zu haben und jetzt darüber über die
Hintertür fängt dieser Kulturkampf rund
ums Geschlecht hier gerade erst richtig
an in den USA läuft jetzt seit ein paar
Jahren und die USA sind leider aktuell
eine Vorschau auf das was uns auch an
Forderungen noch erwartet also ich will
nur einen Gedanken ich wollte einmal
noch mal sagen es gibt ja jetzt
tatsächlich auch eine wirkness
Unternehmen sagen dass sie besonders ja
dass sie Box sind dass sie eben auch auf
ihr Image achten und dass sie das auch
in Bezug auf das Gendern tun wollen und
natürlich logischerweise auf alle
anderen ist man auch das kostet auch
nicht so viel wie gerechtere Löhne und
wie niedrige Preise bei Produkten also
ist es tatsächlich auch ein
es ist ein Ersatz
diversität ist kein Image Diversität
kann nicht benutzt werden um
bühnenwashing zu betreiben sondern
Diversität erstens ist da das ist
erstmal ganz wichtig die washing ist sie
tut weh also auch das gehört noch mal
dazu und ich glaube auch dass es ganz
wichtig ist die Frage wurde
zwischendurch gestellt dass man mit den
Menschen darüber spricht die davon
betroffen sind das ist sowieso erstmal
die erste Regel und da ist es
tatsächlich so dass es gar nicht um
diese ja offensichtliche Solidarität
geht sondern das ist um ganz konkrete
Lebenswirklichkeit geht beispielsweise
in niedrig und Sektor wo sehr viele
Menschen mit zuwendungsgeschichte
unterwegs sind dieses Video wo einem das
Lachen so ein bisschen im Heise stecken
geblieben ist aber wo jemand im Zug
geschrieben hat Ausländer raus und dann
ist der Luxury ausgestiegen also man
kann das ja mal sozusagen Weiterdenken
was das bedeuten würde wenn dieses Land
sozusagen nur noch mit auf deutschen
Gesetze das wäre ja traurig und das
sagen meine deutschen Freunde ja selber
zu mir und ich glaube das ist ganz ganz
wichtig dass wir die
Lebenswirklichkeiten der Menschen alle
über Geschlechtergerechtigkeit
hinausgehen ich würde sagen
intersektional und ist auch ganz wichtig
dass wir da nicht immer nur amerikanisch
drauf gucken wenn wir dort von der
blacklife matter Bewegung reden dann
müssen wir hier von Mike und life mir
das Sprechen Menschen die in Hanau
getötet worden sind die sahen aus wie
ich und meine Eltern und wenn wir über
die gepackten Koffer reden dann können
sie ja mal mit diesen Menschen darüber
reden mit was für einem Unwohlsein sie
auf die Straße gehen und wenn jemand der
schwul ist Angst hat auf die Straße zu
gehen dann ist das nicht nur das Problem
des schwul ist unser aller Problem klar
also ich glaube um diese Frage zu
beantworten was kann man tun und wie
kann man es tun es kommt auf das wie an
tatsächlich und es bringt nichts wenn
wir uns alle in particular Interessen
verlieren sondern es geht eigentlich um
dieses Demokratie Konzept der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit um auch die
Schönheit von Demokratie so zart und
dünn sie auch ist als Lack aber warum es
sich lohnt und warum wir diese Sehnsucht
sind und da finde ich uns wahnsinnig
schlecht tatsächlich und eine Firma die
tatsächlich zahlt auch gerechte Löhne
weil die eben auch Betroffenen und Armut
betroffenen Menschen mitdenkt so und
dann gucken wir trotzdem noch mal was
die Menschen in
einer jüngsten Meinungsumfrage sagen
nur 48% der Deutschen glauben ihre
politische Meinung frei sagen zu können
37% haben das Gefühl vorsichtig sein zu
müssen der Rest ist unentschieden das
ist ein historisch niedriger Wert
noch mal die Frage warum ist der so hoch
Handy darüber liegen und kann das dann
eine
wahrnehmungstäuschung sein wenn so viele
Menschen sagen ich kann in diesem Land
nicht mehr meine Meinung sagen also ich
glaube auch da ist ganz guten Rückblick
sagen wir mal in den 50er und 60er
Jahren hatten die Leute auch das Gefühl
nicht so ohne weiteres freie agieren zu
können und ihre Meinung frei äußern zu
können manche haben wir über ihren
eigenen Hintergrund geredet dann tue ich
das jetzt auch mal
was wir Kinder gar nicht wussten war
dass meine Eltern aus seiner frei Denker
Tradition kommen wir sind aber getauft
und wir sind zum Konfirmationsunterricht
geschickt worden ja ich bin Jahrgang
1954 und ich habe dann irgendwann mal
nachgefragt warum eigentlich ja man muss
vorsichtig sein die restaurationsphase
die Kirchen sind jetzt so stark so es
ist harmlos im Vergleich zu anderen
Geschichten aber es war die Atmosphäre
in den 50er auch noch frühen 60er Jahren
Zeit vorsichtig äußert euch nicht in
einer Weise die am Ende die Karrieren
und so weiter kaputt macht und ich habe
die 68er Bewegung ja im Ausläufer
mitbekommen habe viele sehr kritisch
gesehen die Ideologisierung vieles
andere aber das war eine große Leistung
wir 68er Bewegung USA Europa fast
gleichermaßen hat eine Art von Befreiung
mit sich gebracht die Leute konnten sehr
unterschiedlich Leben sich sehr
unterschiedlich ausdrücken ich bringe
Beispiel weil die Leute es gibt mir gern
nicht glauben sei Georg Immendorf
erinnern sie noch
Künstler der war Vorstandsmitglied der
komponistischen Partei also maoistische
Partei er war grüne Anhänger der
sogenannten Kulturrevolution die zehn
Jahre dauert der 64 bis 74
in China die 20 Millionen Tote
mindestens nach sich zog weil gern
gesehener Gast in China niemand kam auf
die Idee keine Ausstellungen mit ihm zu
machen selbst in der ARGE tropfphase in
der also schon sich deutlich bekannte zu
sein
mauistisch kommunistischen Positionen
gibt sogar ein kleines Museum da in
Italien dazu ist niemand auf die Idee
gekommen zu sagen im Moment der ist
Anhänger eines üble menschenschlechters
was stimmtem übler Menschen schlechter
den können wir nicht mal ausstellen da
haben wir jetzt eine andere Stimmung das
heißt diese sozusagen
libertäre ganz eigentlich gegen die
Ziele der wichtigsten Vertreter der 68er
Bewegung die ihr eher marxistisch sich
definierten aber sie hatten kulturell
eine libertäre Grundhaltung die setzte
sich zunächst einmal durch und die geht
jetzt massiv zurück deswegen diese
nähen die wir
haben mit mir und vielleicht können wir
danach noch mal fragen wie gehen wir
also es ist ja im Raum wie geht man mit
einem Xavier Naidoo um mit Herrn waters
um mit Rammstein um ähm sollen das
Konzert sollen die Konzerte verboten wir
in ihren Augen man könnte ja irgendwie
auch einfach beschließen nicht
hinzugehen wenn man andere Auffassung
ist ja in der Idealvorstellung würden
die Menschen sich auch einfach aufgrund
dieser Vorwürfe dazu entscheiden nicht
hinzugehen wenn wir aufgeklärt genug
werden und genügend Vertrauen hätten
in die die Personen die diese
Beschuldigung gemacht haben dann würden
wir einfach alle nicht hingehen und dann
wäre das Thema damit gegessen jetzt sind
wir aber leider als Gesamtgesellschaft
nicht an dem Punkt also es reicht zwar
wenn ein Mann sagt er war es nicht und
um zu um ihn freizusprechen
gesellschaftlich aber wenn das tut ja
auch noch keiner das ist eine
Übertreibung
also seine Fans sprechen ihn ja
teilweise schon davon feiern können sich
das nicht vorstellen dann wird bitte
Unschuldsvermutung irgendwie um sich
geworfen die er sowieso nur juristischer
Begriff ist aber erstmal es ist nur ein
juristischer Begriff sagen Sie also
erstmal ist ja davon auszugehen
auch dazu zu hören erstmal müsste es ein
Verfahren geben man müsste ihn dazu
hören sie ist interessant weil letztlich
ist es natürlich mit Hass und mit eben
solchen Überzeugungen so dass sie auf in
einer juristischen Grauzone sind weil
man kann sie eben eigentlich nicht
verbieten wenn wir aber über diesen
Straftatbestand reden muss man ja
fairerweise ein Verfahren abwarten
natürlich muss man ein Verfahren
abwarten um ihn rechtskräftig so
betiteln zu können aber jetzt habe ich
auch aus meiner also ich spreche mal von
meiner eigenen Erfahrung mir ist leider
auch sowas passiert mit 17 ich habe vier
Jahre gebraucht um das überhaupt als
Vergewaltigung betiteln zu können weil
ich überhaupt nicht verstanden habe was
in diesem Moment passiert ist ich war
unter so stark im alkoholeinflusst dass
ich wieder in der Lage waren ja oder
nein zu sagen ich habe vier Jahre und
sehr viel Therapie gebraucht das so
betiteln zu können
hätte ich es mit 21 angezeigt wer nichts
passiert heißt das dass die Person
diesen Übergriff an mir deshalb nicht
begangen hat natürlich nicht also wir
reden ja hier von etwas was sehr sehr
schwer beweisbar ist und nur ein ganz
ganz kleiner Bruchteil der Menschen die
wegen sexueller Übergriffigkeit
besonders wegen Vergewaltigung angezeigt
werden werden überhaupt verurteilt
obwohl oft ziemlich klar ist dass da was
passiert sein muss aber trotzdem müsste
man diesen Vorgang doch jetzt erstmal
abwarten oder würden Sie sagen er steht
es ist in ihren Augen eigentlich ein
Täter und wenn er kein Täter ist wäre er
in jedem Fall Opfer dass dieser Gedanke
für zu weit ist er in ihren Augen ein
Täter ist die Frage ich rede dazu ja ich
bin dazu geneigt den Dutzenden
inzwischen sind wir glaube ich schon in
dreistelligen Bereich angekommen Frauen
zu glauben was ist der einen Person die
sagt das ist nichts passiert jetzt
kommen ja immer mehr Vorwürfe dazu es
merkt sich immer mehr ob davon im
Nachhinein was beweisbar ist ist
natürlich die Frage aber das ist eine
juristische Frage die Frage ist eine
andere wie wir das gesellschaftlich
aushandeln möchten und da bin ich auf
jeden Fall bei den Opfern und da gilt
für mich persönlich das ist wirklich
ganz oft persönlicher Ebene egal ob es
rammstein ist oder ob es ein Fall in
meinem direkten Umfeld ist am Ende
glaube ich lieber einer Lügnerin als ein
Vergewaltiger
okay
okay muss ich glaube ich erst mal drüber
nachdenken möchte sich irgendwie jemand
Häusern ja ich möchte mich schon dazu
äußern also das eine ist ja was man
widerlich findet was man ablehnt was man
kritisiert und so weiter das ist die
eine Frage aber Regeln des Rechtsstaates
Unschuldsvermutung das ist nicht
irgendwie juristisches Spiel sondern es
geht darum eben genau das zu verhindern
dass volksstimmungen durchschlagen dass
Menschen ihre berufliche Existenz
verlieren ich bringe mal ein Beispiel
auch die Details nicht so präsent aber
der US-amerikanische Superstar Stacy ja
dem vorgeworfen wurde irgendwann weiß
nicht wann lange ist es her ein jungen
Mann belästigt zu haben nicht
vergewaltigt sondern belästigt zu haben
frei gesprochen unter dessen wurde aus
den ganzen Filmen rausgeschnitten der
hat kein einziges Engagement mehr
bekommen bevor es überhaupt dein erstes
Gerichtsurteil gegeben hat dass ihn
verurteilt das ist die Gefährdung des
Rechtsfriedens also Rechtsfrieden heißt
es gibt erstmal mundschutzvermutung es
gibt viele Vorwürfe die permanent
irgendwie grassieren und dann ist es
Sache der Gerichte das zu klären dass
bei manchen Fällen Ergebnisse rauskommen
die einen nicht befriedigen so oder so
nicht vor kurzem ist ein
Amerikaner wie hieß der jetzt mal nach
13 Jahren oder so frei gekommen wo sich
herausgestellt hat der
Vergewaltigungsvorwurf stimmte nicht
weil übrigens ein schwarzer Amerikaner
das gibt es ja auch also ich vertraue
nicht dass das alles immer gut ausgeht
ja völlig klar dass das manchmal nicht
gut ausgeht aus Mangel an Beweisen
Freisprüche die man schrecklich findet
kann man wirklich nicht sagen das glaube
ich das wird kein JuristInnen da
zustimmen aber es kommen solche Fälle
kommen vor aber das berechtigt uns nicht
an die Stelle des Rechtsstaat zu treten
und zu sagen so jetzt nehmen wir das mal
in die Hand ja öffentliche Debatten ist
das eine aber canceln entlassen
Sanktionen verhängen das ist etwas das
müssen wir dieser Institution instruktur
der Demokratie nach wie vor anvertrauen
weil sonst erodieren die Grundlagen und
zwar sehr schnell auch von rechts wir
erleben das Massiv auch von rechts sonst
hängen zu schnell Menschen an digitalen
marterfällen eben an im Netz das ist
vielleicht eine letzte Frage die wir uns
ganz schnell noch gönnen in
Anführungsstrichen können Düsen wie sehr
spielt da das Netz auch die Rolle dass
wir eben das ist jetzt ein Anfang von
einem Gespräch natürlich auch von einem
Streit dass wir uns aussuchen mit wem
wir streiten und wenn wir noch
überzeugen wollen und können aber
eigentlich müssen wir aushalten uns auch
mit unserem politischen Gegner
wenigstens auseinanderzusetzen und auch
mit dem gefühlten fallen dort
auseinanderzusetzen ja und das sage ich
manchmal zu bezweifeln tatsächlich auch
aufgrund von Ressourcen und einem Tag
der nur 24 Stunden hat habe ich für mich
irgendwann die Entscheidung getroffen
dass die Lebenswirklichkeit draußen
stattfindet und dass ich meine Energie
konstruktiv einsetzen will das heißt
nicht dass ich blind oder ignorant bin
sondern dass ich genau diese Probleme
Versuche mit Lösungen zu adressieren und
die Tötungsabsicht die digitale das ist
tatsächlich ein Bestandteil von känzel
culture und das hat ja mal ein berühmter
Philosoph gesagt auf dessen Namen mich
jetzt natürlich wieder nicht komme aber
der hat eben gesagt dass die
Tötungsabsicht immer dann erfolgt wenn
wir es nicht mehr in die Augen gucken
und ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig diese
positive macht der Begegnung in
bürgerdialogen beispielsweise das ist
etwas was wir mit unserer
bildungsinstitutative machen auch in den
neuen Bundesländern mit den Menschen mal
in den Austausch zu gehen mit denen zu
sprechen die abzuholen also auch das wie
wir aufgewachsen sind und ich kann das
verstehen dass die Leute Sehnsucht haben
nach heile Welt und dass sie Angst haben
sie haben Angst davor wie rasant sich
die Welt verändert hat das kann Menschen
auch überfordern und ich glaube da
brauchen wir Brückenbauer wir brauchen
Menschen die das auch adressieren und
übersetzen können auch als Vermittler
und das ist eigentlich das was wir
versuchen vorzuleben und deswegen
interessiert mich eigentlich immer nicht
was gesagt wird sondern nicht
interessiert das Handeln und was gemacht
wird und darauf wollen wir uns
konzentrieren dann wird sie doch
Politiker finden wir jetzt Beispiel
und wir finden dass es vielleicht
wirklich ganz gut ist ich finde diesen
sanften Weg ja auch ganz toll ich glaube
wir alle sind uns darüber einig dass wir
den sanften Weg beschreiten sollten aber
man darf nicht vergessen dass die dass
die Gegenseite militant ist und was hat
man dem entgegenzusetzen ob man da auch
mit
sandwertet
auch gegen Rechtsextremismus Islamismus
unsere unser Leben ist nicht sanft es
ist auch nicht unanstrengend da gehört
auch Mut zu aber es geht um eine mutige
Gesellschaft natürlich dabei auch nicht
vergessen dass Geduld der Luxus der
privilegierten ist also wir können jetzt
sagen wir machen das mit
Transidentität mit queren Identitäten
mit migrantischen Identitäten so wir
kämpfen ganz langsam für die Akzeptanz
eben im Beitrag war von einem
sprachlichen Kampf die Rede aber es ist
ja kein sprachlicher Kampf jede jeden
Tag an dem wir Geduld haben damit an dem
wir abwarten sterben Menschen daran
erleben Menschen Gewalt dann im
Materialen Leben und ich will genau und
da war die Stimme nach oben und
eigentlich will ich jetzt dann trotzdem
den Punkt machen weil es glaube ich ein
zu guter Gedanke ist als dass wir noch
länger darüber sprechen auch wenn uns
sehr danach ist ich darf mich ganz
herzlich bedanken für dieses reden über
das reden und nicht nur über das reden
und gebe sie sofort live und in Farbe
weiter zu Markus Lanz der heute unter
anderem ein Vertreter der letzten
Generation bei sich hat und Michelle
Friedmann und
Manfred Lütz und wir sehen uns wenn Sie
mögen am
31.08 wieder das ist eine Weile hin wir
machen jetzt unsere Sommerpause sie
bleiben hoffentlich gesund und passen
gut auf sich auf und auf ihren Nachbarn
danke schön bye bye vielen Dank
[Musik]